in two german cities lies the birthplace
of a worldwide arts revolution
one which looked to strip buildings from
unnecessary adornments and build the
foundation of what is called modern
architecture
welcome to the home of bauhaus
[Music]
it all started here weimar university
1919.
this is where german architect walter
gropius alongside other artists founded
the bauhaus movement his office alludes
to what the architectural style would
become a force for clean simple designs
fit for the everyday life
not too far away in weimar is the first
official bauhaus building house i'm horn
built for an exhibition in 1923.
its clean lines and lack of adornments
might look average today but almost 100
years ago it was truly revolutionary
70 miles away in decile the movement
continued in 1925 initiating its most
fruitful period the most stunning
representation is the bauhaus dessau
seen as the pivotal building in bauhaus
this structure amazed the world with its
steel frame construction and
asymmetrical plan nearby you also have
other buildings in the bauhaus style the
industrialist minimalist aesthetic is
visible in all of them
in 1932 the bauhaus school moved to
berlin where it dissolved itself a year
later due to the nazi regime
nevertheless the movement spread all
around the world creating an
international trend for all other
spheres of art
[Music]
you